[Música]
quiero platicarles una historia que
sucedió a mediados del año pasado tengo
un par de muy buenos amigos los pueden
ver en la fotografía esta de su derecha
hacia la izquierda cristian arnoldo y yo
el año pasado a mediación de año
aproximadamente
cristian tuvo una operación de rodilla
esta era su segunda operación
nosotros somos maratonistas y nos
conocimos literalmente en la calle
entrenando la primera operación que tuvo
cristian en un año antes año y medio
antes aproximadamente había sido una
operación muy muy sencilla
fue prácticamente ambulatoria y a los 15
días él ya estaba corriendo nuevamente
cuando él nos avisa arnoldo ya mí que lo
van a operar nuevamente pues la verdad
es que para nosotros era algo
prácticamente transaccional porque nos
dice oye va a ser una operación súper
sencilla es no es un seguimiento de la
primera tampoco es algo que haya quedado
mal simplemente me imagino que su lesión
evolución no
por el correr y lo tenían que operar
nuevamente llega él al hospital lo
operan estamos en contacto
telefónicamente y por whatsapp sale de
la operación y nos manda un mensaje
diciendo que está súper bien que la
operación fue muy sencilla y que en un
par de noche iba a pasar un par de
noches en el hospital y posteriormente
se iba a ir a su casa de hecho a través
de nuestro grupo de whatsapp quedamos de
ponernos de acuerdo para ir a cenar
cuando él ya estuviera un poco mejor yo
le calculo si la vez pasada a los 15
días él ya estaba corriendo pues a lo
mejor 23 semanas nos ponemos de acuerdo
el tiempo fue pasando la verdad es que
seguíamos conversando por nuestro grupo
de whatsapp pero no concretábamos nada
no nos poníamos de acuerdo con nada y
llega a diciembre habían pasado unos 34
meses aproximadamente y arnoldo dice oye
vamos a juntarnos para navidad
procuramos siempre navidad tener un par
de reuniones una reunión con nuestras
esposas y previamente una reunión
nosotros solos para empezar a planear la
segunda reunión entonces dice arnold oye
vamos a juntarnos yo le contesto sí por
supuesto y van los mensajes y vienen los
mensajes y qué fecha puedes y qué día
puedes tú pero cristian no contestada
aparecían las palomitas azules
traicioneras del whatsapp
que ya lo había leído pero no hacía nada
y no decía nada la verdad es que no le
di mucha importancia supuse que estaba
trabajando que estaba ocupado o
cualquier cosa al día siguiente que no
había respuesta le empecé a insistir por
el whatsapp y le empecé a mandar algunos
mensajes no los comparto porque a lo
mejor no son aptos para este grupo pero
cuando le sabía que te pasa por qué no
contestas qué es lo que te sucede
y contexto de repente empezó cristiano
está escribiendo y se tardaba y venía y
si no y que aparece su mensaje
nos dice palabras más palabras menos
compás la verdad es que no tengo ganas
de verlos
no quiero armarles un escándalo no
quiero armarles un pancho pero no quiero
verlos
de entrada yo me quedé así como bueno y
ahora que sigue y ahora que viene yo
esperaba el humor negro esperaba el
chiste esperaba el meme esperaba una
foto de su asador ya con el carbón
prendido y los cortes de carne ya listos
para ponerse en la parrilla pero no hubo
nada entonces pues le empecé a mandar
unos unos mensajes preguntándole güey
qué te pasa por qué no contestas nada su
fue más o menos al mediodía llegando
llegando la noche de ese día de goya
dejame le marcó a ver qué le pasa porque
creo que al en serio hay en su mensaje
le marcó luego de que cristian compa qué
te pasa por qué por qué por qué eso que
que hay que yo no estoy viendo que que
no me estoy dando cuenta que se mira
compa la verdad lo que les puse en el
chat es totalmente cierto no quiero
verlos no quiero armar les un tango para
que nos vemos
respira y elige cristian qué te pasa o
sea qué pasó y se mira después de la
operación yo tuve muchísimo dolor hubo
noches incluso que no podía dormir hubo
días que no podía salir de la cama y de
ustedes dos ni media palabra de ustedes
dos no supe nada no fueron para ayudarme
no fueron para ir a mi casa no fueron
para ver qué era lo que yo estaba
necesitando en ese momento
respira nuevamente y le dije sabes que
cristian no supe qué contestarle algo le
dije algo la inventé tienes tienes razón
sí discúlpame cualquier cosa dice
cualquier cosa para salir del paso en el
momento cuelgo el teléfono y lo primero
que hago por supuesto es levantar
nuevamente el tubo en donde acierte no
se levantan los teléfonos agarro el
celular nuevamente y le picó para
marcarle a arnoldo
y le digo arnoldo oye wey hablando
ahorita con cristian me dice que trae
esto
la reacción de arnoldo fue épica dijo
palabras más palabras menos que no sea
payaso por favor la verdad es que no lo
dijo con esas palabras ni fue ese
lenguaje exacto verdad pero nuevamente
creo que sería más conveniente no
repetir exactamente lo que dijo yo
estaba pensando lo mismo que arnoldo en
ese momento por dios que no sepa jazz o
si tanto le dolía
hubiera marcado como que el celular
habla de aquí para allá y de allá para
acá y los mensajes de whatsapp es
exactamente lo mismo pero platicando con
arnoldo le dije oye algo algo algo algo
me está haciendo ruido qué pasó qué es
lo que está viendo
cristian que nosotros nos estamos viendo
y qué es lo que cristian está viviendo
que nosotros no alcanzamos a ver
entonces terminó la llamada y a mí el
tema me seguía dando vueltas me seguía
dando muchas vueltas algo algo no estaba
conectando en mí porque cristian si hay
tanta confianza si realmente somos uno
de sus mejores amigos porque no tuvo el
valor de levantar el teléfono y decir
rogelio necesito que me ayudes en esto
arnoldo necesito que pasen por mí si nos
marca cuando tenemos una cena cinco
minutos antes de llegar para que pasemos
al supermercado a comprar quién sabe qué
cosa que se le olvidó comprar y que es
desviarnos y llegar porque para algo
grave no nos estaba buscando porque no
nos estaba marcando
pero por el otro lado que me estaba
sucediendo a mí en ese momento porque yo
no tuve la iniciativa porque yo no pude
irlo a buscar y decirle oye quedamos de
vernos ya pasaron 34 meses todo bien
es que ni siquiera un todo bien ni
siquiera un algo y ahí es donde llegué a
la conclusión de que no todos vemos lo
mismo no todos estamos escuchando lo
mismo pero sobre todo el más importante
no todos estamos sintiendo lo mismo
y esa fue una reflexión que la verdad es
dije súper sencillo no es rocket science
no es nada diferente pero ahí estaba y
estaba sucediendo y nosotros no nos
estábamos dando cuenta y había una
persona que en ese momento tenía mucho
dolor y entonces de esta situación a mí
me surgieron dos preguntas súper
poderosas
realmente existe o hay un solo mundo y
todos tenemos que ponernos de acuerdo
para ver ese mundo
o si por el contrario hay tantos mundos
como personas sabemos en él y no es
menor la pregunta déjenme les digo no es
no es algo no es algo sencillo porque si
solamente hubiera un mundo mis
posibilidades se reducen a dos y yo
tengo la razón o yo estoy equivocado
y como explicación es algo súper triste
súper triste
y entonces caemos en cuenta que hay
tantas personas hay tantos mundos
como personas sabemos en él y cuando
caemos en eso decimos es cierto así es
como deben de suceder las cosas pero
entonces cómo solucionamos los temas
cómo nos ponemos de acuerdo cuando no
nos ponemos de acuerdo de la única
manera que nos han enseñado es de chicos
discutiendo discutiendo discutiendo
discutiendo y es saber quién levanta la
voz más alto y a ver quién dice la
última palabra ya ver quién tiene la
razón por qué porque no estoy siendo
consciente que el otro es un legítimo
observador del mundo porque no estoy
habitando mis conversaciones con los
otros desde la ternura
y entonces quiero tener yo la razón
y no es menor lo que estamos platicando
porque si nosotros actuamos según vemos
al mundo cómo es que estamos actuando
desde nuestro observador porque si
nosotros como les comento actuamos según
observamos como nos estamos relacionando
como estamos amando cómo estamos
sintiendo cómo estamos viendo a los
demás qué fue lo que pasó en esta
historia que cristian no tuvo la
suficiencia no tuvo el valor para pedir
ayuda
y que fue como les comentaba hace unos
momentos que nosotros no tuvimos ese
estar ahí
ese ser oferta para otra persona para
otra persona que se supone que es
nuestro amigo que es nuestro mejor amigo
a donde quiero ir con esta conversación
con esta conversación quiero invitarlos
a que reflexionemos acerca de cómo
estamos interactuando como los demás
nunca olvidarnos del por qué porque él
está pensando eso porque lo estoy
pensando yo qué contexto hay en lo que
está viviendo cuál es su historia
personal qué es lo que se está contando
qué hay detrás de sus conversaciones hay
dolor hay necesidad hay alegría hay
felicidad y entonces las conversaciones
se vuelven super diferentes dependiendo
de donde estoy yo emocionalmente y si mi
conversación y mi emociones diferentes
porque estoy viendo una cosa totalmente
distinta cuando tengamos una
conversación preguntémonos qué está
sintiendo él
que estoy sintiendo yo que están
sintiendo los demás y si lo hacemos
créanme vamos a crear conversaciones
súper poderosas y vamos a eliminar el 75
u 85 por ciento de los problemas que
tenemos en las conversaciones por
whatsapp o telefónicamente
por cierto cuando esto termino mi
plática no sin antes decirles que la
foto que vieron al principio fue la foto
de la reconciliación es en casa de
cristian la verdad es que seguimos
siendo excelentes amigos y ahora ha
sucedido algo súper diferente y súper
padre cada vez que hay un problema de
cualquiera de nosotros y lo ponen ese
wat en ese grupo de whatsapp
los otros dos estamos ahí peleando por
ver quién quién los resuelven nos
estamos haciendo cargo de los demás
porque ahora sí estamos viendo cuál es
el observador de la otra persona muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]